vamos con el problema 28 en el problema
28 nos piden determinar si x es un
entero x es entero entero ok en el
primer enunciado nos dicen que x entre
12 se enteró x entre 2 es entero será
esto suficiente para determinar si x ese
sentido yo digo que sí de hecho esto nos
permite concluir que x es un entero par
lo cual es más que decir que simplemente
x es entero por ejemplo si x entre 2 es
igual a 7 entonces multiplicando por 2
de ambos lados nos queda que x es igual
a 2 por 7 o sea 14 pero no importa que
el número haya sido este si es un entero
entonces x será 2 veces es entero y por
lo tanto el inciso número 1 es
suficiente para responder esta pregunta
de acá vale vamos a ver qué nos dice el
inciso número 2 nos dice que 2x es
entero
es entero yo digo que esto de acá no es
información suficiente para determinar
para determinar si x es entero o no y la
cosa es que existen números que al
multiplicarlos por 2 se vuelven enteros
pero que ellos no son enteros por
ejemplo si x es igual a 3 medios
entonces 2x es igual a 32 x es igual a 3
si éste es 'un entonces entonces 2x es
igual a 3 pero x no fue entero y 2x y
por otro lado si x es igual a 7 entonces
2x es igual a 14 y entonces ahí tenemos
un ejemplo de un entero que al
multiplicarlo por 2da entero entonces
pues saber que 2x es entero no es
suficiente para determinar si x es
entero o no vale como lo muestran estos
ejemplos entonces aquí le voy a poner
está chiquita y por lo tanto la
respuesta es ah
la respuesta es a vamos al problema 29
problema 29 muy bien en el problema 29
nos piden determinar el valor de x y en
el enunciado 1 nos dicen que 2 x más uno
es igual a cero con esto por supuesto
que podemos determinar x verdad es una
ecuación lineal en la cual podemos
despejar así que ya le podemos poner su
palomita de que suficiente pero como nos
da curiosidad determinar el valor de x
pues vamos a despejar lo de aquí
restando uno de ambos lados nos queda
que 2x es igual a menos 1 y dividiendo
entre 2 de ambos lados nos queda que x
es igual a menos un medio vale muy bien
entonces el inciso 1 es suficiente no
tuvimos que hacer esta cuenta pero bueno
la hicimos por curiosidad vamos a ver
qué dice el inciso 2 en el inciso 2 nos
dicen que x + 1 al cuadrado es igual a x
al cuadrado aquí podríamos tener la la
tentación de eliminar estos elevar al
cuadrado pero no se puede hacer esto hay
que tener cuidado con los signos verdad
si al cuadrado es igual a b cuadrada
entonces es igual a más menos b
creo que para no meternos en esas
complicaciones lo que tenemos que hacer
es desarrollar este binomio al cuadrado
haciendo eso nos queda que x al cuadrado
más 2 x más uno es igual a x al cuadrado
restando x al cuadrado de los dos lados
nos queda que 2 x más uno es igual a
cero y entonces regresamos a este caso
de donde ya sabemos que si se puede
responder el problema entonces la
respuesta sería de lo cual quiere decir
que cualquiera de los dos incisos nos
permite responder la pregunta muy bien
vamos al problema 30 en el problema 30
nos piden determinar el valor de 1 entre
acá más 1 entre r entonces nos piden el
valor de esta expresión ok en el inciso
de información 1 nos dan la suma nos
dicen que acá más cr es igual a 20 y con
esto a mí no se me ocurre cómo podemos
encontrar esta expresión dicho sería
bueno encontrar esta expresión de otra
forma para ver cómo relacionarla con la
suma y creo que va a tener que ver con
hacer esta suma de fracciones va déjame
hacerla a ver el denominador común
el denominador común sería k por r cada
x r y entonces uno entre acá es lo mismo
que r entre ca por r verdad se cancelan
las heras y queda uno entre acá y este
uno entre r sería un k entre k por r
entonces saber esta suma simplemente es
conocer el numerador de la fracción pero
todavía tendremos todavía tendríamos que
conocer el denominador vamos a ver qué
nos dice el inciso 2 el inciso 2 pues el
inciso 2 justo nos dice que cada x r es
igual a 64 que por sí mismo no nos sirve
únicamente nos da el denominador pero si
juntamos las dos si juntamos esta con
esta entonces podemos determinar la
fracción de acá vale no la voy a
encontrar simplemente nos interesa que
podemos hacerlo entonces la respuesta
sería c cada una por separado no
funciona pero juntando las dos podemos
responder la pregunta muy bien vamos
ahora al problema 31 dejan de hacerlo en
color naranja
problema 31 que dice lo siguiente x x es
igual a alguno de estos números x es
igual a un cuarto o es igual a tres
octavos o es igual a dos quintos
a dos quintos y lo que nos piden es
determinar el valor de x muy bien en el
inciso 1 en el enunciado 1 nos dicen que
un cuarto es menor que x que es menor
que un medio vamos a ver qué información
podemos sacar de aquí la voy a marcar en
color verde entonces y aquí le gana un
cuarto x no puede ser un cuarto tres
octavos le ganó un cuarto entonces este
sí podría ser dos quintos le gana un
cuarto
entonces éste también podría ser x tiene
que ser menor que un medio un cuarto
tiene que ser menor que un medio pero un
cuarto ya no es por este lado tres
octavos es menor que un medio cada dos
quintos es menor que un medio ajá
entonces tenemos que con el inciso 1 x
puede ser o tres octavos o dos quintos
si no hice mal las cuentas vale bueno
entonces todavía no podemos determinar
el valor de x le voy a poner que esté
por sí mismo no es suficiente pero a lo
mejor si lo combinamos con el inciso 2
obtenemos el valor de x el inciso 2 dice
que un tercio un tercio es menor que x
es menor que tres quintos
que tres quintos esto lo voy a marcar en
color amarillo entonces x le tiene que
ganar a un tercio un cuarto no le gana
un tercio entonces un cuarto no puede
ser tres octavos y le gana porque tres
octavos le gana tres novenos que es un
tercio dos quintos también le gana un
tercio verdad porque seis le gana a
cinco ok entonces ésta podría ser
podrían vamos al otro lado un cuarto es
menor que tres quintos sí pero pues no
cumplió lo otro
tres octavos es menor que tres quintos
ajada y dos quintos es menor que tres
quintos ajá entonces no nos dice nada
nuevo el inciso 2
otra vez nos pone las posibilidades aquí
o acá entonces pues el inciso 2 no es
suficiente y ni siquiera combinando
ambos incisos podemos obtener el valor
de x vale entonces la respuesta sería
que es justo eso que ni siquiera
combinando los dos obtenemos la
respuesta entonces nos quedaría eso y
finalmente vamos al problema 32
el problema 32 es de geometría ok
entonces tenemos que dibujar un
triángulo pq r voy a dibujar el
triángulo más o menos así
voy a ponerle por ahí pe por acá y por
acá ere y nos dice lo siguiente en el
triángulo p q r
sabemos que pq me de x qué qr mide x2 vr
mide x2 y qpr mide y muy bien y lo que
tenemos que hacer es determinar cuál de
los tres ángulos de los tres ángulos es
el más grande entonces la pregunta es el
ángulo
ángulo mayor
mayor para esto tenemos que recordar o
bueno a lo mejor ya tengas la intuición
pero bueno es un hecho que el ángulo más
grande es opuesto al lado más grande del
triángulo entonces preguntarnos por el
ángulo más grande básicamente es
preguntarnos por cuál de estos lados es
el lado más grande así que si las
opciones de alguna forma nos permiten
relacionar con estos valores entonces
pues podremos determinar cuál es el
ángulo el ángulo más grande vale vamos a
ver qué opciones nos dan en el inciso 1
nos dicen que es igual
es igual a x + 3 esto está re bueno si
es igual a x 3 déjame marcarlo en
naranja si este es igual x 3 entonces
pues tenemos que el orden de los lados
es este es el menor éste es el del medio
y este es el más grande y con eso
podemos determinar que este es el ángulo
más grande entonces esta información es
suficiente vale entonces pues ahí
tenemos x x + 2 x + 3 todo funcionó muy
bien vamos a ver qué sucede con el
inciso 2 en el inciso 2 nos dicen que x
es igual a 2 a lo mejor hay que pensar
este con calma pero yo creo que no
debería funcionar porque no nos dicen
nada acerca de iu o al menos no debería
funcionar por sí mismo a ver entonces si
x es igual a 2 tenemos que este lado me
de que este lado de acá mide 2 que este
lado de acá mide 4 pero que podría tener
varios valores verdad si se abre mucho o
sea si este p se abre mucho y sigue
midiendo 2 que podría ser pues muy
cercano a 6 como 5.5 pero si éste se
cierra mucho entonces ya sería muy
cercano a 2 y porque pues este x que
mide 2 llegaría como a la mitad
y de aquí para acá serían como otros dos
entonces yo podría ser como 2.1 digamos
vale entonces pues no podemos saber cuál
de los lados es el más grande podría ser
o podría ser
vr x más 2 entonces esta información de
acá no es suficiente por sí misma para
determinar cuál es el ángulo más grande
muy bien entonces pues la primera si fue
suficiente la segunda no fue suficiente
y entonces la respuesta es a la primera
es suficiente pero la segunda no vamos a
seguir con estos problemas en el
siguiente vídeo